et voilà je n'ai pas de camp un groupe
de personnes seulement pour les spirales
et ses filles et sa wii wheel et chérie
mais sortez moi d'autres parce que j'ai
dit y opéraient dans philosophie
magazine trouvez-moi détour et moi des
verbatim
impressionnant je peux arrêter l'info
sur le mieux c'est beau cette phrase je
n'ai pas de temps jamais je n'en parle
jamais mais joli eagle depuis des années
[Rires]
c'est pas nous
c'est pas une balle vous êtes rôle ou
quoi mettez-moi d'autres trucs vous avez
mois nike pourrissement je sais tout une
interview produits l'auto magazine est
au détour de ses choix ses soirées
showbiz c'est ma wii fit vous lisez quoi
de égal
mais je lit plein de traces des gueules
bah ouais bah oui bien sûr j'adore
donnez moi une femme je vous donnais de
qui ce sera allez allez trouvez moi de
trucs en témoin cette merde alors il
fonde en train d'assurer j'ai fait une
interview c'est de deux heures avec
philosophie
ils vont trouver d'autres trucs vous
inquiétez pas c'est incroyable
regardez vous accueillez depuis quelques
années des personnalités béni oui oui
quel regard portez-vous sur la crise de
la démocratie que cette crise n'est
qu'un moment des gatif de la marche de
l'histoire en finalement de l'espèce
c'est beau et je prends très mal
m
bonne chance
je vais venir notre homme est bouleversé
public parce que je suis con comme une
[ __ ]
salle à la maison je vais je suis dit
alors cette crise n'est qu'un moment
négatif dont il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
de traverser de part en part pourant
transcender la négative à l'aune de la
conscience purement subjective qui
s'éprouve dans sa liberté mort à
l'intérieur comme négation né en teasant
de l'extériorité celle de la nature
comme celle de la communauté de l'état
voila voila apres voilà mais précisément
non obstant et son auto absolutisation
j'éprouve en même temps dans la
précarité foncière d'une liberté
indéterminée pour autant qu'elle ne
connaît dans l'objectivité des trous
elle se conforme à la conscience
d'autrui aucune assise qui pussent l'a
fondée en soi et points
est il bon de sortie shopping
philosophie magazine et voilà comment
115 ch turbo temps du satis mutandis ça
veut dire quoi
consultations de l'individu de l'état
national par la médiation duquel
seulement la conscience une équipe
remaniée
fait penser à des briques qu'on a eu
dans l'aude
voilà voilà les gars et voilà regarder
je parle de tp mpls que je vais
modestement dans tpm p à l'heure où
l'oiseau de minerve
regardez regardez spam au sahara est
consigné la mine une aide individuelle
et un ratio net c'est ce que je fais
modestement dans tes peu près cyril
hanouna relais mais ça c'est beau ce que
j'ai bien dit coco mais vous savez bien
l'avouer mais c'est une interview ouais
c'est moi à cyril hanouna c'est qui oui
mais vous l'avez bien là bravo
formidable à dire que vous pensez qu'on
incrimine c'est
moi qui ai subi sa patronne elle
s'assure à face avec le journaliste de
philosophie magazine d'ailleurs je vous
invite à élire philosophie magazine
voilà une autre phrase à pour leur
permet leur donner n'hésitez pas voilà
mes thézan voilà
ça c'est beau voile est votre plus belle
interview
sincérité le coeur il ya tout dedans
voir et m'a pas grossièreté pas dans les
arènes
où est ce que vous avez demandé à relire
l'interview pour comprendre xavier
j'ai beaucoup de peine ce que vous dites
ça m'a beaucoup de peine et sachets bon
je vous le dis c'est philosophie
magazine qui m'a demandé ils sont mais
ils m'ont appelée money voilà on
aimerait faire je crois que c'était une
vanne ou démodés ce qu'on peut faire une
interview vous si les bombes avec
complaisait à céréales en fait c'est sûr
que c'est réel oui c'est passé pas de
caméra cachée vanek rothschild croyais
qu'on a inventé tout ça bah oui mais non
c'est maintenant qu'il donne un film a
gagné mais ces philosophies maniwaki
jeudi avec grand plaisir parce que
j'adore la philosophie et bien j'ai
regardé pendant des années la philo
selon philippe babin
sur tf1
donc voila et regarder voilà et donc
j'ai fait des interviews et franchement
bon je vous dis la vérité je les prépare
avec un prof de philo
sûr mais j'ai des face à face à votre le
mec je sortis tout ça il est reparti je
peux vous dire que est également
descendu 2 et touch
et de votre esprit philosophique aussi
d'accoucher mais en tout cas y avait un
gros montant
non mais je vous le dis bon bande de
cons c'est un poisson d'avril
c'est philosophie magazine qui ont fait
croire ils ont fait une fausse il
franchement
c'est mon pote yannick qui m'appelait
pour me dire on garde cette rigolade
parce que moi je suis pas bonne à
philosophie magazine malheureusement et
voilà donc je dis ressorti s accroît
franchement bravo parce que je sais que
c'est
[Applaudissements]